alors bon soir alors bon je vais vous je
vais commencer par une anecdote je suis
rentré à nouakchott ça fait à peu près
trois ans et quand je viens en fait en
général donc quand je rencontre des
femmes qui veulent en savoir un peu plus
sur moi donc il me pose des questions
pour savoir qu'est ce que je suis je
suis devenu ou tout simplement pour en
connaître davantage sur moi donc je leur
dis que j'étais en france et que j'ai
fait donc deux mémoires de recherche sur
le féminisme islamique et autres sur
l'engagement politique et associatif des
femmes en mauritanie
mais bon j'ai l'impression que c'est pas
suffisant et qu'il faut que j'argumente
un peu plus alors je continue en disant
oui donc je suis rentré j'ai commencé à
travailler ici dans une dans une banque
et puis ensuite je fais aussi un petit
peu dans la société civile
mais là j'ai l'impression qu'il manque
encore quelque chose les gens sont
encore sur leur faim alors je continue
je commence à réfléchir je me dis oui
j'ai fait aussi un peu de politique
parfois j'écris des publications il sut
profs aussi de t d à la faculté de
nouakchott mais là j'ai l'impression
qu'il manque encore quelque chose alors
bonjour je commence à réfléchir et je me
dis oui je fais aussi je prépare aussi
une thèse sur le phénomène du divorce en
mauritanie
mais là j'ai l'impression que ce n'est
pas encore suffisant sinon alors en
général mes interlocutrices des femmes
en général elles me disent mais s'ils
n'ont pas encore fondé de famille donc
en gros voilà quel que soit ce que ce
que font les femmes ici quel que soit ce
qu'ils entreprennent en général on est
plus concentré sur le statut social sur
le rôle social qu'elle doive qu'elle
doit faire
donc maintenant je sais pas oui donc
voilà le sujet que je vais traiter
aujourd'hui donc c'est le féminisme ou
l'illusion de l'émancipation
c'est-à-dire l'euphémisme face à la
norme sociale c'est à dire la force de
la mort de la norme sociale sur ce qu'on
appellerait le féminisme donc ça donc je
vais donc il ya deux termes de deux
concepts majeurs sur lesquels je
voudrais me pencher c'est le terme
féminise et normes sociales alors le
premier féminisme donc c'est un
mouvement revendicatif qui luttent donc
pour l'égalité entre les sexes et pour
aussi donc l'émancipation de la femme et
le féminisme c'est pas seulement un
mouvement s'est pas seulement des
discours mais c'est aussi une posture au
fur et à mesure qu'on avance dans le
temps
aujourd'hui le féminisme a tendance à
être perçue aussi comme une attitude
comme une façon de penser
c'est à dire une femme qui agit tous les
jours d'une façon à vouloir contrer le
patriarcat vouloir un petit peu se
démarquer de ceux que nous dans notre
esprit on cantonne dans l'espace féminin
donc maintenant si on se penche sur le
concept de normes sociales
donc l'armée social c'est quoi c'est un
ensemble de codes et de valeurs qui
régissent les comportements dans une
société dont on a besoin de la norme
sociale pour qu'on puisse interagir les
uns avec les autres pour pouvoir
distinguer le bien du mal pour on a
besoin de ça pour vivre en collectivité
donc la norme sociale ça englobe les
valeurs l'école les traditions notre
mode de pensée
maintenant l'essentiel en fait le
message central ici donc vous le verrez
au fur et à mesure c'est d'essayer de
comprendre c'est quoi le rôle ou l'
influence de la norme sociale sur le
féminisme en soi d'euphémisme pour moi
sanglote comme je vous ai dit un
ensemble de choses mais aussi est tout
simplement la place quoi qui est conféré
à la femme dans une société à un moment
donné de l'histoire
je vais commencer par vous surprendre
avec deux citations de deux grands
penseurs et philosophes qui ont
énormément influencé notre pensée
aujourd'hui 10 républicaine avec nos
grandes pensées de le trop grande
en fait cette cette façon qu'on a de
percevoir la modernité comme étant
aujourd'hui les valeurs démocratiques et
républicaines ont été inspirés par ces
gens là et quand vous voyez ce qu'il
veut c'est qu'ils vont dire vous allez
être surpris
donc voilà donc l'amour donc ça c'est
jean jacques rousseau
l'amour a été inventé par les femmes
pour permettre à ce sexe de dominer
alors qu'ils étaient faits pour obéir ce
ruisseau à genève entre et un en suisse
voltaire les femmes ressembler aux
girouettes
elle se fixe quand elle se rouille ils
nous ont gâtés donc ces philosophes des
lumières on est tous d'accord là dessus
ils sont aujourd'hui vrai sable devrait
vraisemblablement les grands
quand on pense à la modernité quand on
pense à la démocratie quand on pense à
la république quand on pense à l'égalité
directement en agent jacques rousseau et
voltaire en tête mais il faut savoir
c'est pour ça que je suis en train de
vous dire ici qu'il faut toujours
prendre du recul par rapport à la norme
sociale ambiante
parce que ces discours un petit éclat
c'est je veux dire ces intellectuels à
ces penseurs ils sont dans une dans une
dans une époque où la misogynie ou ces
citations là ne sont pas du tout
considérés comme misogyne
au contraire c'est amusant c'est drôle
alors qu'aujourd'hui quelqu'un un
intellectuel qui se permettrait de dire
ce genre de situation ce serait
complètement aberrant aberrant essais et
serait mis à l'écart donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut toujours savoir que quelles
que soient en fait notre place
intellectuelle les discours qu'on a il
faut savoir qu'il n'ya pas une distance
si grande que ça avec la norme sociale
ambiante
je continue je vous préviens les femmes
faut vraiment que vous ouvrez votre
esprit ce soir donc on a ici gustave le
bon il y à une notable proportion de la
population féminine dont les crânes se
rapproche plus par le cerveau de ceux
des gorille que des craintes du sexe
masculin
donc ça c'est une des citations
scientifiques les plus sérieuses de
gustave lebon qui datent donc du 19e
siècle
il faut savoir que gustave lebon n'était
pas seulement un anthropologue et
sociologue reconnu mais c'était aussi un
scientifique c'est à dire que il essayé
de montrer à travers ces théories
scientifiques de rationaliser le fait
que la femme était inférieure à l'homme
et ça faisait débat dans l'est dans les
discussions scientifiques des plus
sérieuses et dans les publications
scientifiques tout ça tout bonnement je
reviens à cette façon de percevoir la
femme comme en fait ils essayent
d'expliquer scientifiquement la place de
la femme inférieur cantonnait à l'espace
prévu privée qui n'est pas présente dans
l'espace public pour expliquer et de
montrer qu'elles seraient moins
intelligentes que les hommes mais en
fait au lieu de se poser la question de
se dire si elle est restée là bas c'est
bien pour une raison si parce qu'on on
lui a empêché justement d'y accéder
donc
maintenant c'est pour ça en fait que je
voudrais que vous ce que moi j'ai un
message à vous faire passer d'après si
je pense avoir bien compris l'esprit du
tedx c'est que vous sortiez d'ici avec
comment dirais-je une pour rejoindre ce
que disait monsieur l'ambassadeur
l'objectivité c'est la chose la plus
difficile qu'on puisse avoir c'est à
dire prendre du recul par rapport à ce
qui est institué comme étant une vérité
immuable qu'on ne pourrait pas changer
et il en va de même pour le
questionnement sur la place de la femme
est ce que la norme sociale lui permet
de penser ou pas et ça revient au même
si on pense donc s'il ya à peine 70 ans
vous savez qu'en france en 1945 on
accorder le droit de vote pour les
femmes il ya soixante dix ans à peine
dans un pays occidental reconnus dont
pour pour les droits de l'homme
ça fait à peine 70 ans que les femmes
ont droit de vote alors aujourd'hui si
on en parle si c'est considéré comme
absolument banal et mais à cette époque
là c'est une véritable révolution
c'est pour ça qu'il faut se dire une
chose ce qui est considéré aujourd'hui
comme avant gardiste moderne
révolutionnaire ne le sera plus dans
quelques années et il s'inscrire à skis
aujourd'hui hors norme
il sera absolument dans la normalité sq
et s'inscrira dans le normal de demain
donc je voudrais aussi me pencher sur
l'exemple de la mauritanie la mauritanie
aujourd'hui on a tendance tous à penser
que la situation de la femme est presque
parfaite en mauritanie qui n'y a pas de
problème qu'elle vit absolument comme
une déesse comme une princesse
on nous bassine avec ça tous les jours
et mois honnêtement j'en peux plus parce
que je vais vous si on se penche
concrètement sur l'effet sur les
chiffres voilà mille trente trois 33 133
cas de violence conjugale 302 violence
contre les filles domestiques mineurs
343 violence 343 cas pardon de mariages
forcés de ce oui les mariages forcés et
une violence en soit on s'en est rendu
compte ça fait une dizaine d'années 272
ul contre des mineurs 16 victimes de cas
de traite de file donc c'est en plus
dites vous que même quand je filme
petite parenthèse les chiffres on a du
mal à les trouver c'est uniquement la
société civile en général qui arrivent à
se mettre sur le terrain pour essayer
d'en extraire quelques uns quelques-uns
et une fille sur quatre est marié dès
l'âge de 12 ans une fissure de dès l'âge
de 14 ans trois filles sur quatre à
l'âge de 17 ans en mauritanie
bon vous pouvez le dire parfois ceux des
mariages consenti certes mais derrière
c'est ce genre de pratique là il ya
aussi une déscolarisation des filles
c'était donc c'est une violence en soi
donc moi personnellement j'ai connu
mieux comme émancipation
des femmes donc c'est pour sa part dont
c'est pour ça que il faut toujours
remettre en cause parce que quand on dit
que ce qu'est ce qui pose problème en
mauritanie c'est que cette pré notion ce
préjugé comme quoi la femme
mauritanienne est dans une situation
idyllique
c'est parce qu'on a comparé au pire
c'est tout simplement aussi parce que on
se repose sur certains acquis sociaux
que je ne nie pas au sein de la sphère
domestique mais qui aujourd'hui ne
peuvent plus appliquer dans la sphère
publique dans le monde du travail
donc ces salles le réel blocage donc on
pourrait se dire est ce que ce féminisme
social est réellement est il réellement
au service de l'émancipation des femmes
donc qu'est ce qui se passe en
mauritanie donc quand je faisais mes
recherches sur le sur l'engagement
politique et associatif des femmes en
mauritanie
j'ai interviewé quelques femmes des
leaders d'opinion des leaders en termes
politiques qui était actrice de la
société civile et ces femmes là en fait
ne se posait pas du tout la question si
elle était féminine soupe à la question
ne se posait même pas c'est à dire que
pour elle je suis mauritanienne je n'ai
pas besoin de savoir si je suis sous
vraiment le look du patriarcat ou pas
mais c'est ça le problème c'est que on
leur a inculqué cette façon de se dire
que tout va bien je suis pas en train de
généraliser mais quand on voit leur
comportement avec la gente masculine sur
au sein donc bien sûr de l'espace public
on voit qu'il ya ce qu'on appelle le
négoce féminisme qui est une
caractéristique de l'activisme féminin
en afrique c'est à dire qu'il ya une
négociation qui se crée entre les hommes
et les femmes pour négocier le terrain
d'accord moi je vais avoir un certain
nombre de pouvoirs dans l'espace public
mais il ya un certain nombre de
responsabilités qui sera toujours
conférer aux hommes parce que c'est une
affaire d'hommes c'est une histoire
d'hommes et c'est encore en fait ça qui
fait le blocage encore aujourd'hui et
dont on a du mal en fait apercevoir les
traces parce que c'est marqué par un
ensemble discours un ensemble d'à priori
sur la situation de la femme en
mauritanie
donc c'est pour ça que je voudrais bien
posé je me pose la question est ce que
les discours féministes sont vraiment au
service de l'émancipation
étant donné que les discours féministe
entre ce qui distingue en fait la femme
de l'homme ce qui distingue justement le
fait qu'elle soit émancipé ou pas on
devrait se poser la question
ce type de discours là ne vient pas du
ciel il est imprégné de des réalités
sociales des réalités locales qu'il ya
donc il n'est pas dénué de tout a priori
de tous types de tout en fait préjugés
c'est pour ça qu'il faut prendre de la
distance par rapport aux réalités vrai
peu sur des chiffres sur se comparer
avec les pays où la situation de la
femme serait meilleur
donc voilà maintenant vu que je
travaille ma thèse en ce moment je
travaille sur le phénomène du divorce en
mauritanie
pourquoi dehors parce que j'ai remarqué
que c'était un concept quand on pose la
question aux gens le divorce est
considéré comme étant valorisant pour la
femme c'est normal c'est bien et les
plus libres et je me suis penché là
dessus parce que moi je ne suis pas je
ne suis pas dupe j'ai appris à ne pas
être naïf quand on pratique patriarcal
parce qu'ils étaient très vicieux on
arrive à masquer une réalité qui serait
au service de la fumée en réalité pas du
tout ça ne fait que la cantonner à un
espace quant aux vols dont paul le
phénomène du divorce en mauritanie dont
on sait que 49% des mariages en
mauritanie et finissent par un par un
divorce on eyal c'est le taux le plus
élevé en fait dans le monde arabe
d'après certaines statistiques
donc voilà on se pose la question
pourquoi il ya plusieurs raisons à cela
premièrement déjà on garde à l'esprit
que c'est considéré comme étant positif
c'est bien la femme arrivent à cumuler
ses terres c'est vrai qu'il ya ce qu'on
appelle des carrières matrimoniale il ya
des femmes qui arrive à construire leur
capitale économique et leur capital
relationnel le capital relationnel est
très très important dans un pays comme
le nôtre où on a besoin de relations
pour se situer pour augmenter son
pouvoir également le capital économique
mais uniquement en collectionnant les
mariages et les divorces c'est ce que
j'appelle donc comme je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure des carrières matrimoniale
mais ça ces femmes là quand on les voit
elles se sentent libres elles se sentent
émancipée je tends mais tant mieux pour
elle mais si on essaie d'aider
construire un petit peu les mécanismes
sociaux qui se cache derrière on voit
une toute autre réalité c'est que n'est
ce pas le propre du féminisme ou le
propre d'être émancipée c'est d'être
indépendante vis-à-vis des hommes mais
là c'est pas du tout le cas parce
qu'elles ne réussissent qu'à travers
leur contraction de mariage
on est d'accord maintenant si donc c'est
pour ça que je dis ici derrière la
plupart des phénomènes déguisé en
victoire féminine se cache une pratique
des plus discriminatoire et c'est là où
je tire mon chapeau au patriarcat à la
domination masculine parce qu'ils ont
ils ont pu inculquer aux femmes leur
propre domination et l'ont perpétrée en
sont très fiers bon maintenant si je me
pense par exemple sur les privilèges de
la maternité la maternité on a tendance
à mettre en avant les privilège d'être
mère d'être une bonne épouse d'être une
bonne soeur une bonne fille etc
c'est très bien mais on l'a on oublie un
côté que le fait de mettre en valeur ce
ce statut là on masque justement le fait
que la femme peut être des scolarisés à
ce prix là la femme ne peut pas monter
forcément à gravir les échelons au sein
du du du secteur professionnel au sein
même du secteur dans l'opinion publique
donc voilà c'est pour ça que je vais
vous faire ici un petit jeu pour vous
montrer en fait la force que qu'à la
norme sociale sur notre esprit c'est
elle qui structurent ce qu'on juge bien
ou mauvais on a besoin de toutes les
façons pas ce que vous croyez moi c'est
ça qui inspire aussi l'aspect juridique
pour faire des lois sa part des
mobilisations sociales qu'il y a mais il
ya ce qu'on appelle la structure binaire
notre esprit comment est-ce qu'il arrive
à structurer les choses
de fait avec une opposition de deux
choses on sait que nous aujourd'hui on
vit dans un monde où il ya le bon et le
mauvais il y a le il ya le noir il ya le
blanc il y a le gentil il ya le méchant
il ya le grand et le petit le mans
essayait de ce jeu c'est vous verrez que
tout est binaire c'est une structure
binaire qui inscrits inconsciemment dans
notre cerveau et que nous permet de
juger des choses alors on va faire ce
petit jeu ensemble grand en face et
petit forts faibles
puissant fragile dur
d'où supérieur inférieur espace public
espace privé ou est-ce que vous
placeriez le féminin et le masculin
donc vous voyez ici que notre esprit
c'est inconscient mais c'est des
structures en fait qui sont ancrées dans
notre inconscient subi un conseil qui
nous permettent justement non seulement
d'identifier les choses mais qui vont
baisser encore plus loin c'est encore
plus vicieux c'est parce que il ya
certaines par exemple pratique qui sont
considérés comme douce comme celle de
l'assistanat comme celle de mater
rennais c'est pour ça qu'il ya plus
d'intérim d'infirmières fille et des
secrétaires
on a du canton on pense sécrétaire on
pense pas garçon n'en pense une femme
bien rangée qui attend qui materne qui
seconde et dans les eaux dans les
entreprises et ce qui est bizarre le
plus marrant c'est que quand ce genre de
pratiques est pratiquée par un homme ça
à coeur tout de suite un aspect plus
noble quand un homme est chef cuisinier
à ses plus nobles mais une femme non
c'est normal
donc c'est pour vous dire que même ceux
cette structure binaire là elle donne de
la valeur à certaines pratiques à
certaines responsabilités a certes à
l'espace public donc ce qui veut dire
aussi la politique etc et la femme est
cantonnée toujours à 7 à cette douceur à
cet assistanat d'accord donc donc ses
activités les attitudes dévolu aux
femmes
ça nous montre que ont aujourd monde
dans lequel on est aujourd'hui les
discours féministe 10 aux femmes
mais allez-y rentrer dans le secteur
professionnel travailler vous avez
absolument le droit vous avez les mêmes
acquis sociaux et les mêmes acquis
d'accord très bien mais le problème
c'est qu'une fois qu'on est dans le
monde actif on fait face à des
réticences en général plus on monte dans
la hiérarchie qu au travail - ya deux
femmes
on reste toujours bas entrer mais reste
en bas c'est aussi je vous je vous faire
un schéma un peu pour que vous
compreniez ce que là où je veux en venir
et le plus marrant c'est que les
pratiques patriarcale maintenues elles
sont en général maintenu par les femmes
vous savez que des activités comme le
gavage comme l'excision comme les
mariages précoces sont entretenus et
perpétré par les femmes elles en sont
parfaitement convaincue c'est bon c'est
pour ça encore que là que je dis que la
norme sociale s'est pas seulement un
violon une violence mais c'est une
violence qu'on a intégré on devient
victime est aussi responsable de la
situation dans laquelle on est donc je
ne sais pas je suis encore à combien de
temps donc là je vais je vais terminer
en disant que voilà il faut jamais il
faut toujours prendre du recul par
rapport à ce qui est
aujourd'hui comme étant une vérité
immuable qu'on ne peut pas changer
essayez de réfléchir sur la le la façon
dont on perçoit les choses à normes
l'évolution aussi des choses ce qui
aujourd'hui normal demain ne le sera
plus et vice versa et je voudrais
terminer par une station que je dis
souvent on a longtemps laissé le monde
aux hommes
et quand on voit aujourd'hui dans quel
état il est j'en veux dire ce serait
bien sûr partager un peu plus pour voir
ce que ça donne